all right
wow we're back we're back
evan what do you think
the nature of consciousness is
the nature of consciousness it's always
important to repeat the question right
um
subjective storytelling
just gonna i guess i'm gonna plant a
flag there
just to start and i know those are just
two words but
i think in some way i just have to like
get something out and then
to start unpacking but that's kind of
where my mind goes right away
subjective storytelling um
because um feed me a little more
feed me a little more give give me a
little bit more um of a framework
um what angle what what side do we want
to come in on this with
i enjoyed your reply oh thank you yeah
yeah i could i could just continue to
unravel that and then you can yeah let's
just unpack
subjective storytelling i like that
let's unpack cool
yeah well so consciousness i think it's
definitely it's a very personal thing
on the one sense which obviously
we both know we've talked about this
off the record many times and
there is a universal aspect to it but
there's also a highly personal aspect to
it
and for whatever reason the personal
[Music]
to me is what immediately comes to the
fore whether that's right wrong
left right up down personal is where i
first go with it because i think you
know in some sense the easiest way to
understand
i guess consciousness as a concept is to
kind of think about
this notion of there were each
with the risk of sounding too
self-involved and too narcissistic we're
all the star
of our own movies right like like there
is a cinematic aspect to
your subjective experience of life right
like the
yes i mean even down to the way that i
think we typify and characterize
experiencing life it is kind of it's
primarily through the visual
in some sense like we were talking about
earlier this idea of
you know what if you had to deprive
yourself of one of the senses
which would be the most prime which
would be
the prime one and i think the visual is
the prime one because it's
what allows you as a conscious
operator to track your movement through
space and time
right the prime one you'd want to keep
and then the prime one you were saying
that you'd want to
remove if forced was olfactory smell was
the one that you guys
indicated earlier in your conversation i
like subjective storytelling
i think subjective storytelling has a
feel to me that
is it's accommodating
was the first sort of adjective that
came to mind it's accommodating
that's right subjective storytelling is
accommodating
and then i also appreciated how you put
the
you gave us the the spectrum right off
the bat because you gave the
super individual and you also gave
the universal yeah and so there's this
spectrum too now i think another
interesting thing for us to talk about
is i think
um maybe like all eight billion people
are familiar with the individual
consciousness
i think that's pretty fair to say yeah
all a billion people yup
familiar with maybe yeah but familiar
with it
at i would say a surface level like the
peak of the iceberg
is conscious awareness
that is almost
involved with something
outside of itself like it's kind of
constantly
interacting with the uh
objective world versus this being the
subjective right so
it would that kind of squares with let
me let me hit this for a second longer
because i think this is interesting to
give us a runway on yeah
so um subjective
storytelling okay and then
we have this sort of like objective
outside and we were talking about um a
lot of people
don't even go into the relationship
between the two the subject and the
object
we don't even do that or the subject and
the subject and the space between this
um so there's that and then
the peak in this case of the iceberg
would be something like
um one that knows that they're conscious
and aware but that they focus
a vast majority if not all of their time
on the objective
outside and then what's below the
you know the 90 of iceberg below that
peak that's above the water is something
along the lines of
the deeper analysis of
what exists beyond the subject
spending vast majority if not all time
on object outside so it would be like if
they
spent more time on investigating
the subject itself so
there's consciousness investigating
itself
as kind of one thing on the iceberg
and then another thing would be that
consciousness investigating its
relationship to other individual
consciousness i see what you're saying
and consciousness investigating its
relationship
with object so but it's relationship not
just
object right i see what you're saying
okay and mostly complex
yeah yeah so we're unpacking the iceberg
here and so
most people take the device
and they um engage with the device
in a way that is um
actually this could be interesting when
when most people let's say
engage with the device let's go to um
let's go to spotify
um so what i would say
is occurring on on the device
is the demo the demo itself is
let's see what is better than that
because i don't really want to get
social let's just let's get my point is
i'll just give i'll just give you the
most macro level on it
the device itself is where
the person
engages with and now there's only a
couple billion people on the planet
that uh engage with the device on a
eight hour per day basis type thing
a lot of people don't have the laptops
computers cell phones
type things smartphones but for those
that do what's occurring for vast
majority of people
from what i've understood is that the
subject
engages with the object like it's an
object that the subject
is only engaging with the object and
focusing their consciousness
on just the object rather than the
subject realizing that it's them their
relationship with the object that they
can investigate in the iceberg
anyway we kind of gave a couple things
consciousness investigating itself
consciousness investigating with other
consciousness
um consciousness investigating its
relationship to objects all
in the iceberg of subjective
storytelling
and understanding um what the nature
of it is what the nature of awareness is
so there's this big peak iceberg of
mostly
subject inter subject immersed
fully in object without investigating
its relationship to it
or it's re or its relationship to what
consciousness is
or its relationship to other
consciousness
i would say that that would be kind of
one of the first
sort of hitbacks that i would do of the
tennis ball to that
right just kind of parsing out what are
the different almost archetypical or
typological
a to b interactions between it's kind of
subject
object in a way and subject subject too
yeah it's like subject investigating
itself is one that
really okay let's do another one quick
most people are most familiar with
subject investigating its relationship
with object
definitely okay so if we were to go one
level up from
just subject being immersed in object
and never investigating its relationship
to object
um that the first one would be subject
realizing it has a relationship to
object
and then it investigating that okay that
would be like
the first thing that would be like for
example the social dilemma
it would be like yeah it would be like
the person finally waking up to the fact
that
um their relationship with the device is
more deep than just
it being an object yeah okay there you
go well i was going to say i mean that's
one level
and almost enlight their levels of
enlightenment in a way right
or you could use awareness it's a more
sophisticated
it's it's a heightening of the the
sophistication level of the awareness
is to me what you're saying right
beautiful hitback so my my argument
would be that
in doing the
process of which we are describing
one becomes much more attune
to the nature of consciousness and the
nature of reality
and the nature of other conscious agents
and the nature of the whole
holism the nature of the whole and so
in doing so one becomes more enlightened
one becomes more
aware one becomes more conscious as a
being
and therefore everything that one does
becomes more moral
more ethical more spiritually awake and
aware
therefore one does not cast malevolence
one does not cast evil
one does not self deal and take
advantage of other people purposely
one uh begins behaving in a way that
butterfly effects out
the highest possible states so that's
why this is
so so important beyond
just what appears to be
um
the tip of the iceberg is very
enthralling and it's captivating and
it's almost it's almost like obsessively
compulsively captivating like
i have to do my best basically on a
moment-to-moment basis of my life
to draw myself away from the enthralling
relationship
that we have on a strictly subject
immersed in object and never trying to
understand the relationship
or the subject investigating itself or
subject
with other subject yeah so okay so if
this is first
one could say that um one takes the
first step into the bottom of the
iceberg towards the bottom of the
iceberg by
that social dilemma analogy let's keep
using that one
i also think in a way being able to even
recognize and codify
that first step if you can even be
aware that that first step exists and
that you're in that stage
that's actually kind of step 1.5 to
getting to number two right that's good
because
in some ways that's in some ways what
you're describing is self-awareness
right it's
yes if you can even conceptualize these
what was it four different levels or
so something like that we're going to
figure it out if you can even
conceptualize those
abstractly even if you haven't really
played them out yet or really manifested
them
in the way you're thinking like if you
can even conceptualize that those exist
you've already transcended step one yes
because it's there's a level of self
awareness there right yes which is kind
of like the uh
the autopilot yeah egoic
consciousness right that's a great yeah
okay
so
something important to remember is that
the
the delphic maxim that was written
on the temple of apollo
about 2500 years ago was
know thyself and the other
two delphic maxims that are
known as the most salient
are
nothing in excess um
and surety brings ruin surety brings ren
yeah ooh exactly so it's like it's like
a dose of
hubris right a dose of humility a dose
of humility to counter hubris
that's a better way to put it um and
then
a uh yeah nothing in excess so
so those are the three but then know
thyself the question would be
why is
know thyself not only written on the
front of the um the temple of apollo at
as the number one delphic maxim but why
is it so
why is it the thing that almost all of
the ancient perennial spiritual
traditions
point to or talk about and they know
thyself
they know thyself what and what now the
next question is what is self right you
said
self-awareness right a lot of people you
know it's very interesting to me because
a lot of people that i know
that went to um
the process of
uh the most common
path that people walk down so in like
robert frost
they took the path that most people walk
down not the one that other people
weren't
okay the people that do that are
typically the people that
tell me um about self-awareness and it's
funny because
really yeah because i ask them i'm like
what does self-awareness mean to you
and that's when things become kind of
interesting because
um it's almost like when you only
understand self-awareness from the
perspective of psychology
but you don't understand self-awareness
from the perspective of spirituality
and so and there's i don't wanna i don't
wanna like
mutually exclusively separate them
because they're not but
um but you can kind of tell when someone
is like that because typically what
they'll do
is they'll say self-awareness but
they'll use that
to as a
is an escape or almost there's
it's a crude word but excuses almost a
word i want to say
so what came to mind when you said the
self-awareness from a spiritual versus
psychological was
to me i think self-awareness to on a
spiritual level is awareness
that how you do or don't
align with the kind of spiritual ideal
meaning the god figure you know how do
you diverge or converge with
the features of that god figure right
that's awareness of because that's the
ideal self
because we all in a best case scenario
we all would embody the
characteristics of godliness right you
know by whatever
whatever you dress it in perhaps is not
as important but
that's right that's beautiful i want to
also take us to what remember what you
said you gave us
right when you broke down into
subjective storytelling you broke it
down into the individual and the
universal
sure okay so this is this is where i
think it'll be good to take this because
i think what
people that say the word self-awareness
from a psychological perspective
they mean the individual yeah they mean
the individual
and they have only studied
self from an individual perspective
so it basically not only again i don't
want to be mutually exclusive because
it's not but i just i just want to say
like
usually people that basically took the
most common path
which is um
whether it be somebody that went through
the normal academic
structure of studying psychology or
whether it be somebody that like enjoyed
because they became
a business person and then they wanted
to know more about psychology and then
they understood what
you know self-awareness was um and
actually in the high-level perception we
could potentially
talk about the individual side as the
north star side
so to a certain extent the the north
star
is really what self what people mean
when they say self-awareness
is they mean from a psychological
perspective or an individual perspective
would be something like
how aware are you of
your consciousness and your
your moment-to-moment awareness and your
north star so your dreams your goals
your aspirations
how aware are you of your roots and your
fruits right your roots
your roots is where you have you know
roots and fruits is one of my favorite
it was
it's uh you guys will see that in when i
break down high level perception in more
detail with my
stack of of notes over there um on
on camera and stuff but so how aware
are you of your roots uh where you have
your lineage you have your if you got
love when you were young
um if you got water food shelter
um the basic needs being met how aware
are you of your traumas your parents
traumas this type of stuff okay
so there's the roots and then there's
the fruits which is how aware
are you you know there's also the the
moment to moment how aware are you of
your moment to moment
beingness and then how aware are you of
your
fruits so how aware are you of your
north star so it's very i'm just saying
it's a very individual right
now where i think the spiritual or the
universal like you said
come into play which many people that
have went down the normal path have
never
touched and don't understand is it's
when you're
you become more porous in chapter nine
in high level perception we talk about
identity
and we talk about porosity and so it's
basically
the evolution of consciousness a wave
evolving beyond transcending and
including as ken wilbur and claire
graves and don beck and chris collins
spiral dynamics and
and what not have said is that you go
from egoic consciousness
to social consciousness to
ethno-consciousness
to worldly consciousness to
transpersonal so now okay and then
nondual and
symphonic we can talk about but i just
want to say this before we do
is that what porosity means is that
you become more and more aware of the
universal you become more and more aware
of the
the depths of the iceberg that are not
just
the subject's relationship to an object
and so this is kind of what we're trying
to unpack
because every time you've noticed it's
funny
we've spent um a week together
in la as evan has been instrumental in
the foundation of the transition of the
simulation recording studio to los
angeles and
evan and i have spent some time also
with not only talking about
consciousness and the nature of reality
ourselves but also with other people
and every time that i've
surgically skillfully tried to
insert consciousness or metaphysics
into a group of people
in discussion it is one of
it may be one of the most difficult
things to do because
people have a proclivity to
want to um keep
consciousness veiled from its own nature
right so it's like the veil
of consciousness investigating itself is
very strong
and so that's why when somebody inserts
a question of
how deeply have you investigated your
source
or how deeply have you investigated your
consciousness these types of questions
the first thing that people do is
typically
especially uh egoic level or
social or ethno level consciousness will
typically do things like
crack a joke brush you off and get back
to its relationship with objects
right away right
that's the proclivity there's a very
strong tendency for so well i think
because it's one of those things where
perhaps in some
if i'm understanding it in one sense of
the way you're describing it
it could be something that by definition
would uncover
flaws in the individual or or aspects in
which they fall short of
i guess you know this universal
consciousness to me i kind of still keep
characterizing in my head is
right how you know if you were to
overlay yourself and your traits with
the traits of like the most godly
figures in history like where do they
align or misalign and that
that kind of uh that overlay and in the
in the cracks and the misalignments most
people are not too uh excited to see
those
right it's just it's not it's not
necessarily a comforting
thing it it pushes back on the ego right
it pushes back on the this is the lower
roots the lower roots yeah this is so
beautiful
so you so you're spot on bringing this
back up so
the universal is not
only the relationship with the
highest possible moral
ethical spiritual states
of existence
and that catalyzing the
individual to actively strive
towards that and sort of investigate its
own roots that way in its moment to
moment being and its
fruits nor star that way but
i would say that also on the universal
exists
the
may i yeah pull that yes thank you we
have uh
some of our images handy
once once you get that ready i'll uh
i'll pull it up for you guys
okay beautiful so what i want to show
you is i want to show you
just watch out for that a key it's a
doozy oh the a key
okay all right so
here's what i'm going to show you guys
and you guys you guys probably remember
this
for those that have have investigated so
all right now
what we're looking at right now is we're
looking at
high level perception
the visual synthesis that i
authored and published two weeks ago
this is chapter nine it's on
consciousness
and this is what i would say is
a little bit closer in the direction of
the universal
so if we begin
unpacking this
this is what you could say
exists in the iceberg
at the lower levels and that
consciousness actively participates in
trying to
veil itself from this reality
sure okay so and this is a very
uncomfortable reality for people
and um also
a lot of but a lot of people are
starting to um to tap into this reality
and and i'll explain how because it's
actually very interesting because
a lot of people are tapping into this
reality by
empathy as we've talked about that's
right that's right we've talked about
that a lot
and that's right it's super interesting
because you basically get
um you get like an evolution of
consciousness
that occurs where people sort of
rank themselves up um and become more
aware and more um
especially more aware of the subject's
relationship to other subjects
and like the subjects kind of
first-person experience
that kind of thing yes it is super
interesting because
people will get to that level of
awareness and it's super cool
but it's but they stop there okay
so let me i'll give you an example so
basically somewhere around like
2 000 and maybe like
14 or something like that let's say
somewhere around
six years ago or so i was maybe 22 and
what happened was i remember
vividly learning my first time in my
life that
there are people that still carry
a jerry can gallon on top of their head
yeah and they have to walk kilometers or
miles
to get water fresh water and bring it
back to themselves right
so this was kind of i would say my first
like
real introduction to kind of
trying to truly get behind
the first person subjective storytelling
perspective of another and so well and
then yeah he's already if i button
and that's interesting that you use that
example too because
though on on in the one sense that is a
subject to subject
it also is true that you've um that is a
kind of an art not an archetypical
um experience but it is a an experience
that's shared
with a large number of people that
particular instance you're seeing so
it's individual to individual empathy
but it's also
individual to population empathy by
nature that being a universal behavior
that's super interesting so because i
think when people a lot of people
a lot of the times when people say
empathy i think it very much is that
like you must be sitting across from
somebody it's like seeing
a look in their eye or a tone in their
voice that makes you
kind of throws you a jar and it makes
you kind of
instantly in that moment aware of some
something that's on their mind
but the level that you're talking about
is it is kind of one more
one step more abstracted from that right
yeah and i think there have been a lot
of great minds that have talked about
how
on a when you when you say something
like
one person is hurting somebody is much
more
very receptive and willing and ruling to
help
but when you say that there are a
million people hurting the person's like
i can't do anything
what can i do about that type six the
scale and it's abstractness
okay exactly so there's that and then i
think another interesting thing that you
just mentioned is that
you have not only is it like you said a
common like
archetypal example of of of i think it's
common for people to
experience their first sort of doses
into
trying to immerse themselves in other
people's more
less less fortunate subjective
storytelling
in the case of uh if we're talking the
approximately
800 million or so people on the planet
that still don't have access to
uh a clean source of of water there's
such an immediacy to that right yeah
yeah there's a huge immediacy and that's
one of the main
routes on the human in high level
perception that we drew is the water
water is one of the main things for the
roots just like it is for the tree it's
the same thing for the human
and this is kind of maslow's hierarchy
in a way right in a way yes
yes and so yeah and so um so not only is
it common for someone to
have a not only is it 800
approximately million people and so the
extension is to a large group of people
that have to undergo some sort of
similar process
in the water procuration also
it's a common thing because it's not
like i had a one-time
experience with evan that triggered
because that's that's a more unique
thing but my experience wasn't that
unique because there are
dozens if not hundreds or thousands of
people on the planet that have had
experiences like that that have
triggered them into okay
so now we're talking now we're talking
into interesting territory so
what i think is what you're seeing now
is i think it's the first sort of taste
of what happens when one nerve ending
if you will of the brain begins
to query begins to
investigate what it is like to be
another nerve ending of the brain
in in essence okay so
without jumping to level 65
um which would be something along the
lines of try and hold
all eight billion people's perspectives
at the same time
because then maybe that would be
a higher level of consciousness than
just trying to hold
one person's perspective at the same
time right so that's
the first taste is when one nerve ending
tries to go to another nerve ending
and tries to understand his first
person's perspective is it good
so one that's an interesting idea one
thought with that too is i think
to make it really tangible i think
another angle which you can think about
this
is to consider the what i would term
you know essentially the emotional
valence of those two models
of kind of empathizing if you will or
understanding
someone's experience because i i would
venture to say
generally speaking highly individualized
experiences around empathy or seeing the
suffering of
another almost always have a much more
intense and lasting emotional valence
than
i think the more you abstract it and the
more people that you're in theory
empathizing
the universal experience of them the
less kind of
emotional pull it has for you and unless
it affects your behavior
interesting because i could also i could
also make a massive
argument against that mm-hmm so
interesting so okay because here here's
the thing
the emotional valence that occurs when
one
really truly gets behind the
problem of 800 million
people not having access to clean water
is significantly
more emotional valence in my opinion
than when one person is communicating to
another person
some sort of deep in this case it would
be if one person was telling me
that they came from a rural village
around the world
where they had to carry a jerry can on
their head
so this is i'm just saying this
sometimes someone's consciousness
can't actually go right away
it kind of levels up slowly in a sense
almost everyone's does this way
not everybody gets immediate kind of
states of
leveling up several times but in the
example where
it would be some sitting down with
somebody
and having them explain to me
about their life about them carrying a
jerry can to get water
what would happen is it would usually
trigger an evolution a really nice
sort of new baseline where i understand
how that's existing in the world
but it doesn't go to the next step
sometimes which is
i wonder how many people experience that
and so the next step is when you go okay
how many people experience that and then
you realize that it's 800 million people
experiencing that
and then the next step is when you try
and hold
800 million people subjective
nerve endings on the planet having
a lack of clean water on a normal basis
and then
sort of the next step after you hold the
space for that
is to say what
can i do entrepreneurially artistically
scientifically in order for me to
help those 800 million people
get clean water
just like we have on tap in modernity
and we have no issue we spend zero
percent of our daily
thinking on an existence on procuring
water
and what would that unleash that's
always the biggest question is
what would it unleash how many beautiful
fruits
would it catalyze of people's north
stars and gifts and ability to not
think primally in search for water this
type of stuff so
i think that there's sort of levels to
becoming more and more aware of what
exists
in the bottom of the iceberg and um
what we just went through as an example
of clean water
and truly holding you know i guess
we we can use this word but in today's
sort of very woke culture um
what occurs is a lot of people
go to the one on one
empathy and and combat and
then the the question that i would
ask is what does it take for the
consciousness to go
to the next levels beyond
and yeah yeah well what i find really
interesting about this
i mean and i think perhaps we're on the
precipice of where
sometimes we end up with this is
what i hear you saying i agree with in
in in a world in which
we are seeking the most ideal version of
how a human brain
could operate or how humans could
operate which
could it best case scenarios can play
out
if if there's we've seen it happen in
the world right we've
set our course towards some sort of
progress and we've been able to achieve
it
but something worth considering is i
think i always end up taking the
position of the kind of like biological
materialist
and on this one that's why i brought up
the emotional valence thing specifically
so
we were talking earlier off off the
camera about um
i brought up this idea that people
only usually take massive action if it
has a
really really strong emotional valence
like it's it's no coincidence that
activists for sexual assault usually
were sexually assaulted right
like there's so many terrible things in
the world
your average person isn't going to wake
up tomorrow and arbitrarily pick one and
become
that level passionate to defending and
eradicating it
unless they had a very personal
experience with it or somebody very
close to them
and they felt the emotional trauma and
and i would make the case that the
reason that is and i would say that this
kind of is
somewhat biologically determinate
because if you look at how we used to
live i mean generally speaking you would
rarely live in a society
where your tribe was more than i believe
150 people right
that was kind of that magic number
dunbar's number so
i think that directly correlates with
that idea that there's probably a
biological evolutionary reason why
there's this kind of emotional valence
and we struggle to
have abstract notions of empathy or
abstract notions of um
suffering they they seem to
tend to not drive massive action in the
same way like these really
hard-hitting personal or you know your
mother your father
your son your daughter these people that
are really close to you just because
i think the human brain at the end of
the day it
the even if you think about how the
brain i think structurally works
there's i think if you look at um what
was it
um phineas uh the gentleman that got the
railroad stick through his head
right like he have you heard about this
gentleman
so he maintained all his cognitive
intellectual capacities
like he could probably
you know he could navigate logical
problems
but he struggled to if my understanding
if i remember is correct
he struggled to put his efforts in a
direct goal-directed way behind anything
because
he the part of his brain that was tied
to emotion had been damaged or severed
from the logical part
and because you need that lot that
emotional engine to
trigger the abstract um start up and
trigger the abstract
logical part of the brain that thing had
been severed in him so he was
it wasn't like he lost intellectual
capability or intelligence he just lost
motivation and that in in my mind that's
kind of a case study and that that
notion that
that's why this kind of subjective low
version is so
potent because it actually has to do
with the brain structure and
you know in a biological material sense
right
not to say that you know i mean perhaps
there is a way that we
um may we try
to hold on maybe we try and hold space
for the universal a little bit more
yeah go ahead okay i think i said mine i
think what
what what typically occurs when
attempting to
investigate the nature of consciousness
and especially consciousness
investigating itself
right that part of the iceberg
specifically again
let's just go back through this because
i think it's so important otherwise
we can get you know what's what's really
nice is like
let's um you know let's
let's specifically get a couple like
layers of this
let's specifically get a couple layers
of this even
uh on our on our visual on our visual
system
via the via the beautiful technology we
have
on our uh over the shoulder shot
so i'll do my best to sort of
keep this in in a good vision for you
guys so
let's begin with our let's begin with
our iceberg
so
so we have this
we'll go here so we have this kind of
like
okay all right
is that is that seen well yeah that's
seen well enough cool
okay great so we have this iceberg
now the
this is kind of your classic iceberg
example where
you have approximately
you have approximately 10 percent
of the iceberg that is above
and you have approximately 90 that is
below
this is a very very frequent analogy and
metaphor
used a lot in life
okay so
now what i want to do is
i want to sort of illustrate
to people where we were
unpacking the majority of
where we're unpacking the majority of
the
nature of consciousness and
potentially that 10 percent
of
the top 10 of the iceberg is what a vast
majority of consciousness
is currently doing so that means if we
go
back here that the vast majority of
consciousness is doing something like
kind of like subject
immersed in object
and then we could say that it is
we'll go a step further and we'll sort
of put a box
around the object it's almost as though
like
the subject's focus is extremely
oriented
on the object and that's the vast
majority of people's
conscious aware experience on a
moment-to-moment basis
okay so now some of the
other states that we were describing
is when this might be closer to like
here
this is like subject
becomes aware of
its relationship
so so subject
subject becomes aware of its
relationship
to objects so here the the subject's
becoming more aware of
of the of the arrow portion okay
it's a good diagram it's clear okay cool
cool especially coming from someone
that's
a designer and architect it's super
duper important
yep you hit all the points you yeah the
least number of elements to
most simply show the idea yeah yeah
that's
exactly that's that's what i that's the
whole thing of
of high level perception yeah also yeah
that's the whole point of this component
to um simulation to the show
is to begin trying to compress i almost
yeah we are attempting to become memetic
gods
on that program yes that's what we are
trying to do
and the
the more that we can compress
the most profound wisdoms
into the most distilled forms
of art dissemination the more
we awaken and win that's right yeah
and not to go down a rabbit hole and i
think this is right on the right track
but
and to cut to communicate things in a
way
complex things in a way that they don't
become complicated right yeah yeah that
kind of decision yes
and and also just a distinction also
that win does not mean like
simulation winning no it's more like win
meaning on
a on a whole level remember holism on
that you meant like charlie sheen
winning
yeah yeah yeah yeah on on i was excited
yeah
we got to get charlie sheen on the
program too we got a lot of people in la
we got to sit down with
that's right perhaps he's enlightened
though he could be we have a we have a
lot of work to do here
i'm so pumped though the journey loved
the journey baby um
so what happens is
is that
if one can when one can
understand on a holism level
the winning
being
of the entirety and not of
some sort of like the the individual can
win in a nash equilibrium at the same
time as the collective can win
that's not a problem we can have that
conversation no problem
but i mean the collective winning on a
metaphysical level
like meaning in diagram number
10 in chapter 10 on infinity in the
second diagram
i give the oroboros and i give
all of the fermi filters which are
things like
asteroids and mutually assure
destruction with nuclear bombs
and uh the planetary
health bar being disintegrated
due to short-termism uh
the code of life being used for
malevolence like biowarfare
and then uh the artificial general
intelligence being
unaligned with with uh the most
uh benevolent outcomes so in what i mean
by winning
is i mean becoming memetic gods
communicating
compressing distilling art that awakens
so that we
win as in we get to the godhead the
gateway
which again i hypothesize as the
metaverse and then we go inward
transcension hypothesis john smart
into the next big bangs into the next
consciousness exploring infinity
okay just to get back to this
i just want to show another thing here
because we made this analogy which is
great
so what what was occurring
was that um was that we
had talked about this one as
the subject's relationship usually with
the let's put it up here with the
with the
these will be our another it's like an
it's funny it's like an analogy
in an analogy actually i've never
thought of that before i think i have
maybe have thought of that before in
some ways but
okay so now we're using an analogy
within an analogy
okay i don't know if you guys can see
that that well but um
okay so i wrote the word i wrote the
word phone
right because it's usually what happens
is we get our most
phone we get immersed in a phone right
okay so
what's occurring in this one is the
subject becomes aware of its
relationship with the phone
i'm addicted to my phone yes so this is
where we write the words
and perhaps that's almost a
psychological self-awareness in a way
right
okay uh yeah yeah because it's a very
tangible version of self-awareness it's
not yes
it has no relationship to spirituality
per se i i
i would i will continue yeah there's
there's more to it but they're not
mutually exclusive things
but yeah social dilemma is what we wrote
there
right okay so we have the
subjects uh i'm fully engrossed in the
phone and spending a vast majority
of their of their time only aware of the
tip of the iceberg which is the phone
um their relationship with just objects
and then in this case
when you get a little bit deeper it you
kind of start getting towards like the
maybe the water line
of the iceberg and you start getting a
little deeper because the subject
becomes aware of its
relationship with the object
in this case it would be like what
social dilemma
catalyzed for people's awareness that's
right
um so excuse me
so what i believe
tristan harris said was that netflix
gave some sort of statistics of
um somewhere around
it's in the tens of millions of people
have watched
and which is pretty awesome that you
there have been that many people that
have watched
now um if if it's true that people have
watched with their families at the same
time like if five people watched at once
and netflix only got the statistic that
one person watched because it was one
account
good point so it might be somewhere
beyond 50 million people
have seen okay so this is the
approximate now what what that's doing
is it's slowly waking people up to their
relationship with object which is really
interesting okay
so now we have that now i would like to
go another layer so is it okay if we
pause on this for a moment
um because i think what's interesting
about this as well
is there's the relationship between
there's the individual understanding how
they're relating
to the object and that's kind of that's
the persepta way
and then there's the people that
institute that dynamic right
as in and that and to me that's kind of
where you start to get into the
territory of 48 laws of power type thing
what there's people that are deploying
those techniques intentionally
assuming that with the assumption that
most folks are operating in
in zone one so they're never gonna
bridge they're never gonna
bridge into zone two and become aware of
that thing they're they're betting on
that
the lack of the that happening right the
the low probability that it will happen
but
this has happened on a mass scale right
it's almost
in a way it's it's a mass awakening an
awareness about
the potentials of psycho psychological
manipulation frankly
right you know yeah and they're they're
they're the same forces and
pressures that we've seen throughout
history the kind of machiavellian
as you bring this up it's important to
remember that
the classic example of um the knife
being used to cut vegetables in your
kitchen or being used to stab
and kill somebody so in in the case it
always the double edged
and so in this case in this case it's
really interesting because what you can
see is you can see that
um the
the peak of the fortune 500 companies
that have created the
uh subjects relationship to objects to
be
very um especially
hyper intimate and
information technology driven
especially in the last couple of decades
is the same
companies that have in a sense enabled
the social dilemma
to have occurred it's bizarre and that's
so bizarre in this sense
so it's super interesting okay so
uh and that's again i write about this
in high level perception in uh chapter
two c theory in the second graphic on
trajectory mechanics when i compare
newton's laws of motion to the evolution
of consciousness
what sri aurobindo and the mother mirror
alfasa taught me before anybody else
was that the spiritual ascent and
descent happened simultaneously
and people like carl jung and jordan
peterson have also been very adamant
about teaching
said things like jung saying that the
roots
must reach down to hell in order for the
flowers the branches the leaves to reach
heaven and so in this case
it would be that the ascent and descent
are happening at the same time meaning
that
the same way that people are becoming
hyper addicted
to their object of their smartphone and
their technology
is the same way that people are is the
same
so that's the decent is the ascent is
happening which is that
people are waking up to their
relationship with objects
and that they should focus on their
relationship
their subjects relationship with the
object because
it is very important to realize what if
you're
not aware and conscious of that what it
can do to potentially
harm and how you can actually augment
your awareness by doing so
so the ascendant decent happens
simultaneously i i think
that has a direct relationship to that
um
[Music]
idea that jordan peterson describes
about i think in his psychological
classes he would always
one of the exercises was to imagine that
you were a nazi
prison guard guard yeah exactly and this
idea that the only way to
frame did you notice i put that in the
epstein documentary
i put that at the very end of the
epstein documentary because
a lot of people um and it's funny
because there were a lot of
out of the tens of thousands of comments
a bunch of them were on high ground
right
a lot of people were getting onto some
moral high ground they were thinking
that i was saying making some claim
about
about jewish people or i was making some
claim about about german
people or i was making some claim about
hitler i was making some claim about
i was making no sort of claims about i
was
only trying to communicate to people the
same way that jordan
taught me right that you should always
get behind
the eyes of the perpetrators and realize
that your name in fact
actually would have been them would have
been quite likely exactly quite likely
would have been them
was the same way that people could have
easily become
epstein elaine matthews if they were put
in those same circumstances or the
the women that decided to um funnel
themselves into those scenarios
um or the men that perpetrated that's
right as well
all the players all the cast of
characters so it's so interesting
watching people take moral high ground
when in reality
um their money is very interestingly i
said this at the beginning of the fc
documentary is
almost always a function that
makes people um ethically succumb
to money that's right so this is what is
very important is to work on oneself to
such a degree
including myself and including everybody
that work on your moral
and ethical and spiritual essence to the
point where
money cannot pervert those fundamental
essences of you yeah so and i think how
you brought that up and it speaks to
what you were saying that there's a
simultaneous
ascension in descension in order to
achieve this middle
relationship awareness and i think that
has an analog to this idea that
you have to descend into almost
imagining the scenario in which you
are converted to a perpetrator
nazi prison guard right in order to
realize that
you have to go down that depth to be
even aware of it
you have to imagine the scenario and
imagine the truth and see the truth
that you probably right would not have
been the moral high ground but only
at that point once you've kind of
traveled down that road in son
sawing yourself naked enough that you
could say that there is a part of me
inside
that would be capable of these these
terrible things that is kind of that
it's it i am capable of being addicted
to my phone yeah
it's admitting it is the first step
right yep and then only from there can
you
begin to mitigate against it yep so
that's right i think yeah
yeah we're so so so spot on so
in that graphic that i showed from
chapter nine
of the
the integral from zero to eight billion
of the all the nerve endings and of
the of consciousness that you can
imagine that some of the nerve endings
of
consciousness have been the perpetrators
at the nazi
prison camps as well as the um
the people involved in the epstein
scandal and so
and so um the more that you
realize that we're taking an integral
we're keeping a holistic perspective
on um everything from the source point
which is hypothesized today
to be a big bang up until um
the eight billion people alive on the
planet at the same time which took a
hundred billion
people and a 100 million
species up until this point there are 10
million species on the planet ish
so what we think right now that you you
have to take the integral of
all of that including what we just
mentioned with nazi
camp cards and people involved in epson
scandal as
all one holistic
unity and um once you begin doing that
um now you're beginning to get into some
transpersonal
in some non-dual states of consciousness
and in symphonic states of consciousness
um so we will hopefully be able to
get there as well so this
i would say is
the sort of slow introduction to
what may be the nature of consciousness
the nature of reality
if you will so let's continue um we will
go
into we had
in the
in the icebergs
below water section
we were also talking about
the subject investigating itself and the
subject investigating other subjects
and the subject investigating the whole
so
we can say
the probably the subject
investigating
other subjects
and then the subject
investigating itself
and then the subject
investigating its relationship with
itself yeah
so so here we have the subject
investigating subjects
which is technically investigating
itself
but if you will play with the nerve
ending investigating the nerve ending or
the cell investigating the cell of the
organism just
play with me and then we have the self
investigating itself
and remember the delphic maxim know
thyself right so
we're slowly working our way and then
there's the self investigating the whole
which is
probably best described by the graphic
that i made for
for chapter number eight
which is called the magic trick for high
level perception
um would you type yeah
sorry guys i wasn't able to get my ndi
connection working with
my laptop so we're just uh using evans
for this let me uh put
uh put that on the center cam just just
so i can i just want to i just want to
really finish just
finish this point quick because i think
you'll be insightful
okay yeah so uh if we go do you wanna
try man or do you wanna yeah i wanna
just i just wanna hit this really quick
so some thoughts great great okay
excellent excellent so
all right so here's here's your
classical graphic for
oh interesting so i
we actually we actually are getting a
small
uh issue where i can't show the
let's see i see what i see i see so can
can can um
i wonder if it's
oh it did activate okay great sorry
awesome thank you
whoo thank you technology all right
all right so i think that this graphic
from chapter 8 the magic trick
does a really good job at
teaching us what it means
for um
for the
subject to investigate the whole
okay so
um it's you know i'm not i'm not going
to be able to i guess
draw the the the whole
magic trick here but maybe the best way
for me to do that is to sort of
give you a
very
a very low
dimensional view of that
where it basically ends up being the
the humans that evolve
on the planet finally begin
to
right they begin to they begin to
inquire
into the magician right so
it's something it's something like
let me see if i can put this up again
for you guys okay
so it's something like this so
the subject begins investigating the
hole which is the magician
that is our source that
then catalyzed a process
where we where we were we
birthed as conscious agents that could
then
contemplate our own source so we could
contemplate our whole
okay all right so now again one more
time
we have we have this i also want to say
the self investigating another self a
subject investigating another subject
is usually deemed in
uh in today's culture
as empathy this is usually the way that
we kind of talk about it um and
we can also another sort of way to
understand it
is when um a lot of people a lot of
people
for those that have been in love before
um
what usually occurs is and this this is
this is not only like
a person romantically falling in love
with another person
and then uh whether it be for a year
or three years or whether it be for
them getting them getting married and
having a kid because what happens then
is you fall in love
with another subject right you fall in
love with your kid
and so then there's there's that
relationship to another
subject that's very intimate and close
that people experience
and then maybe that kid goes on to
themselves also experience
love a lot of what people do is
chase after experiences
that make them feel
closer to god yep and so
whether that be chasing and rupert spira
really taught this well is one of the
leading non-dual teachers of the
of the advaita vedanta direct path
that
a lot of the time that our
experience chasing of
substances or
a one-night stand or any of these sort
of
um love in this case also can be this
way
that is usually because we feel some
sort of a lack
and so it's basically the self not
knowing itself
so if the subject truly was self-aware
which is what we
kind of talked about the beginning that
you would have
a a true
gnosis right a true knowledge as the
greeks would say
you know yourself and if you know
yourself
then you know your source you know
the oneness you know the the
relationship when you have a subject to
subject relationship that it
is the subject in relationship with
itself
the self in relationship with itself um
so and it and it's all on a spectrum of
like we said individual to universal
so we can probably
also
add that to make it a little bit more
also friendly i think
that there's some sort of like uh
there's some sort of like an individual
to universal spectrum that exists
and the whole point in
in my proposal about
symphonic consciousness
is to be able to do
the two simultaneously
so basically if you can merge
if you can merge the individual and the
universal and hold them both at the same
time
that's when you attain symphonic now
what what occurs is you have the hyper
um
this is this is this is the most sort of
um
this is the most common
modern day um analysis of this is you
kind of have
the um
i'll actually use my eastern versus
western yeah
yeah yeah you're spot on so we have the
the very classic sort of like usa
specifically especially the us today in
modern day
and then this could be something like we
can we can probably write
i'd probably write india first and then
kind of like
china something like that yeah okay
so um all right so
we have usa on the individual and we
have the universal with india china
so it's again it's not as like kind of
like binary and stuff like this but just
for us to in a sense
um be able to unpack these things
in ways that are hopefully relatable and
helpful
so um and it's funny because if you guys
remember the
if you guys remember the graphic
thank you by the way have we got any
comments going on oh yeah let's go yeah
yeah totally
this has been so interesting i hope for
other people has too
um i will definitely just go look at
that here i just want to show this so i
can finish this point and then we will
so if you can if you can
as we say in high level perceptions
seventh chapter called the sorting
algorithm
if you can hold the individual
in the collective at the same time
meaning
if you can drain the bath water the
dirty bath water
of individuality and drain the dirty
bath water of collectivism
and if you can uplift the good the the
baby out of the bathwater of
individuality and uplift
the baby out of the bathwater which is
of collectivism and then if you marry
the two together and have them make a
baby what
happens is you synthesize the
best codes from each of them and you
archive the old codes
from from each of them and so that's an
interesting hypothesis that will unpack
a little bit more once we look at the
comments
of of the conversation
and so uh evan and i have been uh
feel free to comment we've been sort of
mentioning um before we started that we
were going to be looking at these
so
we would love to hear from you
let's see what you guys have been
talking about
interesting so so far uh seems to be
it's great been on for a little over an
hour
we thought it was just gonna be an hour
we'll we'll wrap um
soon i'll uh they'll do my best to kind
of finish some of the key i mean it's a
lot of fun i think we should start
yeah i think we should start analyzing
we should move to the next analysis of
this because i certainly have an
abundance of things yeah i mean i think
we've kind of i've heard this
full rehearsal before and i've and
you've heard my reaction so perhaps in
some sense i could
deliver that yeah and so we've had some
interesting comments of not being able
to force a plant to flower early
which is a very it's a common spiritual
phrases you can't actually
pull the flower to make it grow faster
type thing
yeah um and so
well i think someone was appreciating
our points on robindo
people have been talking about the
pareto distribution things like that so
yeah that's kind of what's going on on
the comment stream
so one one interesting to riff off that
idea that pulling the plant too early so
not to go too far um
[Music]
well there's a part of me that that
wants to question the whole
premise of this and i think i've said
this a few times in our conversations
to me a lot of this sounds like the idea
of
how this is this is the steps in which
one might initiate a utopia but the
question let's just transition
because i i know that um it's almost
sorry i just want to say that
there's something about um the there's
like this archetype that occurs in
people's psyche
where they go this guy's a utopian
everybody don't listen to him type thing
and i just
well i just want to say rather than use
the word utopia
let's use the word protopia so if you
look up what the definition of protopia
is
is it simply means we are incrementally
bettering that's it incrementally
better no utopia protopia
incrementally better because it's it's
something that evan's mentioned to me
over the last two weeks or so true
and i would just like to make sure that
we
don't wander down this utopia rabbit
hole rather stick with protopia
just incrementally bettering that's it
yeah so the thing i would say on
if that's the case then the thing i
would say how does this particular
mapping of
where we might go different from what's
already happening irrespective of us
stating or advocating for this model if
just progressive
incremental improvement is already what
we're aiming for that seems to be
what's happening either way right yeah
and that's where
well right yeah so but but also not not
quite
although that is does seem to be what's
happening it's it is not quite that in
the sense that
okay the here's the core claim if if
this
is true if it's if it's true it's very
it's probably the most paramount thing
that
i've learned that will affect
our trajectory if it's
not true then i want to know that it's
not true so i'm very i have a very high
level of openness to learn from other
people that this is not true okay
the the idea which i wrote again in
chapter 10
infinity i wrote the two words darwinian
metaphysics yeah yeah it basically means
that
the natural selection
applies at the universal level
that's all it means so what that means
is that
if it's true so
again if right i'm not dogmatic i am not
fundamental i am extremely open
i have extremely interesting abstract
ideas and i
just want to know what the nature of
reality is
that's all i care about and so i'll just
finish
exactly so i'll just also just finish
the point um so
if it's true because i think this is the
thing
that will change our civilizational
trajectory from incremental betterment
to holy [ __ ] this is extremely important
okay those are two vastly different
things okay
so well yeah so yeah so i think is it
okay
i think we should definitely make this a
dialogue it's super personally yeah okay
that's the point
otherwise you could of course so just i
just want to say darwinian metaphysics
if it's right
then people will uh realize that it's
really important for us to undergo
recursion aka
it's important for us to ethically
morally and spiritually align ourselves
with
christ buddha louds of confucius level
consciousness
and basically try our absolute best to
maximize the flourishing
of every single human seed to its
fullest possible potential
and and create a synthesis of artificial
general intelligence
simulation theory mixed realities
biotech and neurotech
fuse together into the metaverse which
is where we're going which is
potentially where we came from
and so we can actually undergo recursion
into the infinite designer realities
that we create which is potentially
where we came from before the big bang
now if that's not true if if
if there is no darwinian metaphysics if
um
if it's guaranteed that we make it to
the
the next recursion um we it's guaranteed
we make it to the godhead
if that's true then um if it's just
guaranteed so if darwinian metaphysics
does not apply
i want to know that as soon as possible
i'm actively looking for it
to figure it out so well i think
to me darwinian would imply that this is
a
truth truth in in in the material true
sense
and i think to circle back to where we
very started with this conversation
consciousness being subjective
storytelling right
that's kind of where i come at this is
it's not so much
that one story or right is right or
wrong it's just
i think it's how utilitarian and useful
is the story
you see what i mean like because in the
same way in some ways what this
this kind of this world that you've
painted and created through these
the relationships between these ideas
and the architecting of it
to me it it does have shadows and echoes
of
a religious doctrine right and i would
argue that it it's almost birthed of
that right
i think in order to create this
particular um
relationship set that you've set up it
it's a distillation of
many major world religions right so it
it synthesis and just to be clear it's
also a distillation of many
cutting-edge sciences just to be clear
okay because well i mean it's just it's
just very comfortable to sort of like
slot like higher level thinking into
kind of like
um this is an archetypal synthesis of
religion and so this has a lot of
religion essence to it
and so i i just here's the thing you
can't walk around
to um the um somewhere around let's say
five billion or six billion religious
people on the planet
and you can't actually have a um a full
dialectic with them on artificial
general intelligence
blockchains and cryptocurrencies biotech
neurotech
quantum mechanics um geopolitics
geoeconomics
i have very precisely and carefully
become
polymathic to the degree where i have
synthesized
the spiritualities and the sciences and
businesses and arts and all these things
into a very carefully crafted project
again but to me that's
subjective storytelling yeah exactly and
that first thing that you said was fair
i just didn't think that how do you
apply darwinian principles to something
that's inherently subjective
darwinian is a materialist argument
right like that the material truth
in a material materially true world
something will prevail
but in this in this kind of
homogeneous field of ideas where we're
not applying a value judgment because in
my opinion
it's more about how effective is this
meme
of an archetypical story or military arc
like
yeah yeah perhaps this resonates with
a certain percentage of population but
perhaps christianity or some other
doctrine
that still puts you know evolution of
of knowledge of goodness and moral
um virtue at its peak like it
what's to say that it's true in the
in the sense that the relationships
it's relationally true right it's it's
the relationships embedded in them
in this are true in the sense that
they're analogous to all these other
relationships we see in other doctrines
that we consider to be
have proven their value to um
when when deployed appropriately and
when deployed in
in a good face sense lead to good moral
results is
right so if we go one step above
darwinian metaphysics what we arrive at
is consciousness exploring infinity okay
and if consciousness exploring infinity
is true
what happens is darwinian metaphysics is
potentially even
not that
it's not as important because
if the source point if you imagine
as we have in the in as we have in the
infinity
diagram if if this is true
again i am i'm so deeply in love with
being wrong that i have no problem at
all of saying things that might possibly
help people but if if they're wrong and
people can
show that i'm extremely open so
um all right if it's true that
from this this graphic in
high level perception chapter 10
infinity the second graphic
if it's true that from that this has
been juan mandelbrot in the background
has benoit mandelbrot's
um infinite fractal zoom uh it's his
uh mandelbrot set in its maths town on
youtube
is the channel that does a really good
job of this of making these
what i would say is if that's true that
from that center source point right
there in the middle where the green
square is that and then if you go to the
top left corner
where the green square is where the
diamond is at the center
of the prism that is refracting the
source white light into all of its
rainbow combinatorics
that if that's true basically the idea
is something like
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom
that's how fast universes are being
created so
if it's true again it's just a it's just
a thought
that if you look at the top middle that
would be
those would be like the universes that
are being created is something like that
it would look something like the the
universe is being created
super fast like that and that
if consciousness is exploring infinity
and there's all of these different
permutations and combinatorics of
who you are who i am who evan is
who different combinations of math and
physics different combinations of
sentience
being non-carbon based non-dna coded
creatures
um completely different universes that
look kind of like what the top right
corner looks like where it's a little
bit like
worlds that are of your infinite
imagination like what
maybe pixar or walt disney would create
things like that that if that
is all happening this fast
then darwinian metaphysics doesn't apply
as much does not it's not as
important because even if um this
reality does not undergo the recursion
if it does not meet its god head
and go into the metaverse if we if we
completely
obliterate um ourselves with any of the
fermi filters
then what happens if this is true is
potentially conscious agents
uh go into the next
uh births of
exploration on other combinatorics
that are being made so that's the
essence of
potentially consciousness exploring
infinity even transcending darwinian
metaphysics
which is what many of the perennial
spiritual philosophies have talked about
and last thing i would say about it is
that it's always interesting to me
hearing how often people
like haven't studied the
the old and new testament or they
haven't studied sufi metaphysics or they
haven't read the daoda ching or they
haven't read the
four books five classics or they haven't
read the
uh upanishads and studied advaita
vedanta and zogchen and theravada
buddhism and danced
the african vodoon tradition or done
anthogenic medicines of the native
americans or done sweat lodges
and how often people still somehow
haven't done any of those dozen things
but how yet they have formed some sort
of concrete opinion about
perennial spirituality so the reason why
i say that is because
i myself um if you guys remember if
anybody watched the interview i did with
jordan peterson two and a half years ago
what happened was i was 25 years old and
i had only tried theravada buddhism
and i had tried some entheogenic plant
medicines
and i had um
dabbled a little bit in some of the
other um like
major books of spirituality and whatnot
but not too much
so two and a half years ago my my
essence to
jordan peterson was something more along
the lines of there's a lot of dirty bath
water
man that religion and spirituality stuff
there's a lot of dirty bath water can't
science just do
everything and it was funny science is
descriptive not prescriptive right
his his most important thing to think
about right his reaction was very like
um kind of like basically like you know
kid you you're not doing the justice of
the
planetary perennial spiritual
philosophies and wisdoms any justice
because
you have you're 25 and you think you
know but you don't yeah
and so what and so what i've what i see
is i see a lot of 20 year olds
a lot of 30 year olds a lot of 40 year
olds a lot of people
who i spent finally in the year 2020
i spent 10 straight months putting
together these
a lot of high level perception and i
don't want to just focus obviously
consciousness infinity are important but
really you know high level perceptions
core
is really at trying to analogize what
the seed of a tree and the seed of a
human
are and so the human seed needs
nutrients in order for it to produce
fruits that's really like one of the
main core first essences that i that are
given it but
that it's just so surprising that people
that are just a cup like a couple
decades old
will basically throw away the 5 000 year
old planetary spiritualities
because they think that it's just all
dirty bath water
and that the i spent 20 20 specifically
trying to
um immerse myself in all of those dozen
that i described to you
and it was a lot of work i literally
took 10 months to
you know how few people can take 10
months of their lives to do something
like that
that's true very very few people
eventually
that's something i wanted to bring up to
you take one week earlier to do this as
well
yeah and so some people do do that and
then they learn a lot and then they try
and bring that to other people
because i think there's a there's a
reason i brought up maslow's hierarchy
earlier too because i think it
definitely has a relationship to
everything that you've sketched out
yeah because i mean there kind of has
been evidence to show that as societies
progress there's almost an analogous
relationship between the subject object
relationship
and the ability to meet your basic needs
right like literally you could just take
that diagram and put it next to maslow's
hierarchy and
they would be one-to-one you know and
and the reality is
it's only kind of in nations we're in or
parts of the world wherein we don't
we have the luxury of not having to be
not having to be stuck
in s to o constantly that we have the
ability to transcend right
like and i think 800 million people we
listed earlier that were undergoing
transactions
it's gonna be tough for them to get to
the top of maslow's hierarchy or to your
last
option because their brain space is
literally filled with just the bottom of
the pyramid right
and not always correct because a lot of
extremely wealthy
people in modernity are extremely low in
egoic consciousness and a lot of very
poor a lot of very poor people living in
um
international poverty which is less than
two dollars per day
u.s dollars per day are some of the most
enlightened people
which is super interesting so there's a
lot of people that
fit into a different and i described
that again in
chapter six on ai coach in the second
graphic on the biometrics of awakening
that you have a wealth hierarchy next to
uh enlightenment hierarchy
but the funny thing is you don't know
that you don't know where the people
are on the enlightenment hierarchy yeah
so mathematics
hierarchy is an important creative
archetypal structure that
gives us insight like you're describing
it doesn't i just want to be clear it
does not
precisely um articulate
the it's it's it's archetypal yeah
aspect yeah the other thing i got all
the nuance yeah yeah the other thing i
would say is
and you know so alan and i have talked
enough that we know each other's
curveballs and we know each other's
lens that we're going to apply and i
always go psychology first i leave with
psychology so
the really important thing i would say
is if you know the myers-briggs
personality test
which is very similar to the big five
it's although it is not exactly the same
although it says that
the the this the psychoanalysis
of the big five has been proven
uh to be more effective than the myriad
that's right
that's true that is a true statement i
just i just want to be clear
because you do talk about myers-briggs
um a lot but you talk about big five a
lot too but
sure but i just i just want to i just
want to be fair here that it's good
okay okay so that being said there
there's this concept that so within the
myers-briggs it's it's a
um breakdown of it's the first letters e
and i
you're either more extroverted or more
introverted it's obviously a sliding
scale
the second dimension is intuitive or
sensing
sliding scale me and that one's a little
bit less obvious what that means
sensor people that are sensor driven are
more
more naturally predisposed biochemically
to be
oriented towards the physical world
intuitives are much more like allen and
i are probably the audience that are
more interested in ideas right in
in the intangible in making predictions
or projections about the nature of the
world
based on things that are not physical
right they're not just straight
observation
um t or p thinking or feeling uh i think
that one's relatively self-evident and
the last one perceiving
or judging and the thing i think that's
important to remember with all this
is that there is literally all those
relationships statistically in the pot
in the general population
are essentially 50 50 there's about half
extrovert half introvert
half thinking half feeling half
perceiving half judging
the one doozy is intuitive in sensing
there's way way way more sensors than
there are intuitives and
if you think about that from a
biological standpoint was it two-thirds
one-third or three-fourths one-fourth or
what do you mean by believe it was two i
believe it's two-thirds to one-third
okay yeah 66
to 33 66 sensing
exactly 66 of people are naturally
predisposed to be more concerned
frankly physical tactile
physicalism type thing and then uh
subjects uh immersed an object and then
intuitive would be something more like
ideas
and maybe they would want to explore
what the relationship of the subject is
to the object or the subject to itself
via other subjects or things like that
abstract thinking and so the important
thing to think about with that is
i mean there's probably some pretty
clear biological reasons why that would
be i mean
intuitives are going to be much more
valuable and of of utility
in leadership roles are going to be of
utility and teaching roles
but those things relative to the overall
percentage of people operating and doing
and working things in the world
like you need a lot more people
historically that were actually
physically doing things they were
obsessed with the physical world
moving things building things
construction workers you know
fishermen people that are bakers people
that are very in the physical
i mean if we had that if you actually
think about it historically in the way
we used to operate or still kind of do
if that ratio was much more like 50 50
we kind of be in trouble because we'd
have all these people that want to talk
philosophy
all day when we're trying to you know
make sure
we have enough food to survive right or
enough like wood chopped
to you know keep the fire going so it's
so the that that would be the lens and
the the overlay i would lay on top of
this is that
don't ever it's important not to forget
that there literally
are a larger percentage of the
population that's predisposed
to not think this way nor have a
temperamental interest in thinking
abstractly so are you
are you essentially saying something
along the lines of that
excuse me that
over the course of the last six or so
million years of evolution from
the chimpanzee to the human that it
somehow
um ended up that especially maybe in the
last
um couple hundred thousand years or so
that
the uh the the head the 50 50 splits
across
the other um myers-briggs sections
besides
the sensing versus intuitive um
are 50 50 because that's evolutionarily
okay for our trajectory but the one
that is not okay to be evolutionarily 50
50 is
sensing intuitive because in order for
the from about a couple hundred thousand
years ago up until maybe ten thousand
years ago and
and whatnot to have kind of gotten there
um we required
um more people to be sensing so that
they could
ex to be in the physical life primarily
in the physical in the physical
child rearing child reproduction okay
procuring food
i'll say i'll say that i'll give you
like that this is that was an
interesting i liked that point
and let me give you and i actually got
something that might fall into your camp
and but you could probably make a pretty
compelling case that
as we're becoming popular on a
population level
at least in the west less there's less
need for
hands-on in inter kind of kind of work
do you remember what i'm meaning more
synthetic work do you remember what i
wrote
make the case that intuitives will cycle
up in the population as a percentage
you can make that case super interesting
if you
because we'll be the genetically
successful people you know
yeah yeah in 2018 i wrote on the
on my personal website alansand.com in
2018
i wrote uh the phrase we're
not farming comma we're on twitter
period you couldn't i put it couldn't
have put it more concisely that's the
whole mimetic
thing we were talking about and that's
exactly that if you could just put it
into a
potent so so i think i think you're
right that
um it might be true that maybe in the
next
um okay i'll get i'll get a little bit
i'll get a little bit
uh woo in a sense because what what what
happens is you have people that
try and um analogize like an octave
to the evolution of consciousness from
the big bang
until the godhead auroboros and so what
they say is that we are approximately in
the third density
okay and that we're evolving to the
fourth density and beyond
and what would be said is that in the
third density
there is a lot of egoic consciousness
there is a lot of
the subject focusing immersed on just
the physicalism object
and that may be more on the myers-berg
in terms of sensing and that where we're
going into the fourth
is fourth density is more something
along the lines which would be again it
would be something like the e to the f
like c d e f g a b
right in the octave that from the e to
the f what you would see is something
like
people evolving from a self dealing
service to self and go at consciousness
focus on
the subjects focus on the object
immersed in it to
something that's more like service to
other something that's more like
um love wisdom light
um an investigation into the
relationship an investigation into
the self investigation of those things
and then if that's true if you're right
what could be true is that over time
we if we could like again i tried doing
this in ai coach in
in in chapter six in basically the the
the data visualization because we could
technically do what you're talking about
um
if we would actually just more
lo uh we if we if we
kind of just really here look at this if
we
if we gave a little bit more of a [ __ ]
about you know
edward tufte's quote above all
else show the data right that's the
quote on the top of chapter 6 ai coach
here
and if we could visualize the
not only the individual's data like this
but i mentioned how this is
i mentioned how this is scale invariant
meaning it applies not only at the
individual level but you could visualize
kind of like
your family's data you could visualize
your city's data which is something that
bloomberg and the city's initiatives are
doing with smart cities they want to
visualize their data so you can
understand what the
uh what how the economy is doing what
the response time is of the fire
department and of the police department
and
how how how the pool occupancy is doing
and stuff like that so people
yeah so people care about data
visualization
and so if you scale in variants so if
you take it beyond
the level of uh
city you get to like the state or the
country so imagine if the country had
like an operating system of its data
visualization and it could see
what was happening because right now all
you have is you have someone that
occasionally says
the united states is 28 trillion dollars
in debt and then other people go
okay and then they go back to kind of
like their day-to-day [ __ ]
but like if you actually sort of had
like the united states is like
approximately
four to five trillion dollar like yearly
budget and like
where you know a quarter goes to the
military industrial complex
or fifth goes to that a fifth goes to
medicare medicaid a fifth more goes to
those and then
uh you know the like
the little 60 billion dollars that gets
sprinkled into education meanwhile the
military-industrial complex is
700 billion plus so if people could
visualize things like this it would help
awaken them
and we talked about this with data
interoperability in our in our previous
conversation but
then you go up to the planetary level of
planetary level of
of data visualization so imagine if you
had
one of these dashboards for
the planetary health for the planetary
um what you could do potentially is you
could see
the 8 billion humans psychometrics
in a myers-briggs center that would be
interesting and where those deviations
yes occur over time and then you could
see if potentially this
this idea of evolving from the third to
fourth density from a service to self to
a service to other
is potentially actually catalyzing
more and more people to go from sensing
to intuitive
yeah and that's i believe that that
that probably inevitably will happen
because we are building a world and
certainly an economy that trades so much
more on abstract thinking
and than it does on tangible thinking
for sure right i mean
tech and software that's all abstract
reasoning right it's not
i mean there's there's i guess there's a
there's a tangibleness to it
but i mean creative strategy within
those organizations it's all about
synthesizing
a bunch of things in abstractly
synthesizing
metrics within the company itself and
then spitting out you know some sort of
answer
and that can't be done it's it's too
abstract to be done in a sensing fashion
right it's not just tabulation it's
it's analysis and synthetic um
conclusions
yeah that was a really abstract that was
really abstract too but we're totally
heading
it would let me put it this way it would
be hard to be jack dorsey and be a
censor like i guaran i would
because you have to be such a
synthesizer of information to be
that in that role and i think you could
also make a case that we're moving
towards a world where
yeah we're all kind of entrepreneurs or
we're all kind of leading our
organization or you know what i mean
like if we all
are thinking synthetically we all kind
of are ceos like
yeah in that kind of inclusive state
there it is right and that kind of is
that and yeah
and i thought about this before that
there's an odd to
to also speak to your circle analogy
there's there's an odd um
hopefully that's not too far um there's
an odd
recursiveness to that too because if you
actually look back to
and then i'll admit i'm no i'm i'm going
a little bit outside my realm of
expertise but
my understanding at least in kind of a a
layman's sense of like how medieval
economies operated it was always this
like
the the metal the um
the the metal smelter had a shop right
and it was a one-person shop
that was above his home and it was
everybody was kind of like a little
shopkeeper right
and and they would live below or they
would have the shop at the
at the base at the street level and they
would live in an apartment above and
there's this weird bizarre
actual analogy of that we're kind of
going back to that right like where
everybody
has their house and then their computer
is the business
below the house right and it's all kind
of compressed and pretty interesting
it's instead of
we kind of we corporatized and we we
expanded and got massive
like that's what happened over the last
well not even hundreds provided a lot of
interesting
things too yeah i mean and there's
upside but i mean but now we're
drinking right i like that analogy
that's a good one yeah
yeah this is why i really like doing
tennis with evan because he's always
introducing me to uh to things like
keith tatlinger yeah and people like uh
these analogies that are um
even though um and how that triggered
the data interoperability thing and then
how
this right now is triggering a lot of
very
very interesting things because in a
sense that is inclusive stakeholding the
you know the idea that maybe you can set
up a building
where you can live on the top and you
can have your shop below and it can be
in such
city centers where there's maybe only
just a thousand or ten thousand or
something people that live and it's just
this
kind of local cluster of of people that
need uh that need bread and that need
water from aqueducts and that need um
blacksmiths and that need leather and
shoes
and and that need um kind of just basic
basic needs and materials uh carpenters
things like that and then
what's kind of interesting is that if
that idea can
sort of like interconnect with the
modern day
laptop entrepreneur yeah i think that's
decentralization and decentralization so
is it possible that
we kind of is you know this could be
interesting did we possibly move our
trajectory
more from the
sort of inclusive stakeholding
more like everybody was in a sense more
like an entrepreneur sometimes there
would be people that needed to run the
shops that
were just paid a a nickel or whatever an
hour
but that did we potentially have more of
that
and then as a percentage of population
let's say as a percentage of people per
capita
these are always such interesting things
that we don't have like the
archaeological data of that i would
really
love for us to run a simulation we'll
have to pull this up sometime i mean we
would need a sim
i think in order to get a lot of this
archaeological data we need a simulation
of a civilization
and that um that would give us the
insights that we're asking for
so things like if it's if it's true that
back in the day of of what we're
describing that it was that
more people as a percentage of
population were actually
uh inclusively stakeholder as an
entrepreneur that lived above
the business and most people were like
that and then they bartered and
interchanged and stuff like that
versus in modernity what we have is we
have like kind of a handful of fortune
500 companies
that in a sense kind of globalized and
that kind of govern in a sense 800
8 billion people and the economies
then it it might be true that today as a
percentage per
capita it might be true that
we are less inclusively stakeholder than
we were before that we are less
entrepreneurial potentially
than we were before as a percentage of
population maybe
but also it's interesting that's a cool
analogy and it might be
also true that given our like biomimicry
of what we wrote about in chapter 5
inclusive stakeholding
that it might be true that we may be
heading more towards
like how mycorrhizal networks work in a
two-way resource exchange underground
where
we actually feed more and more of the
mother trees these big fortune 500 trees
that they feed more of the sugars that
they make from photosynthesis
to the smaller seedlings in the
understory aka the vast majority of
the eight billion humans that then
enable them to sort of meet those basic
needs and their roots
in order for them to blossom their
fruits and so it might be true that
later on
we might have in maybe a decade or two
once we get these architectures fully in
place and whatnot
that we might have a greater percentage
of the population per capita actually
entrepreneurial oh i think that's
unquestionable i think
that's inevitable interesting yeah when
it also depends on how you define
i think the classical separation between
entrepreneur and
corporate employees also changing too
because
and because think of something like
i mean you could use the word gig
economy but i don't think
so i think a good example of this is a
company like fiverr right that's
essentially just a platform that enables
individual but they don't they're not
inclusively stake held
that's one thing so yeah what what's the
api in the details of yeah what's
occurring with uber
and fiverr and yeah i'm a little i'm
reluctant i'll i'll just quickly look at
the model
because curious go ahead here's what's
happening if if you
if you just go one more level up what
happened was what um
the the idea of a venture capitalist
investing into an entrepreneur in the
capitalist
law and social fabric of the united
states is extremely good
because it's the most entrepreneurial
place on the planet because of the code
of law and we need to appreciate that
everyone
seriously and share that style of code
of law with the world
but the next augmentation to that code
of law is when a
venture capitalist invests into an
entrepreneur that has a team
and you have the founder equity that has
maybe like 10 or so each
the venture capitalists get somewhere
around a couple percentage points
themselves for making the investments
and then what happens is this sort of
pool of let's say
whatever if it's a billion shares or a
billion tokens what happens is you have
a pool of maybe 500 million shares or
500 million tokens
and what you do is you you begin doing
things like the uber drivers or the lyft
drivers or the fiverr employees some
degree of equity
so it's one level you know the silicon
valley really
had that those those vested shares
of common stock for the employees which
was really important to go beyond the
founders to the employee level which is
good
but you can go one level next level of
inclusive stakeholding
which is where like drivers for uber and
lyft would get
tokens or shares based on how much
equity they're actually building for
uber and lyft because if you think about
it out of the
100 billion dollar evaluation and same
thing with the riders actually too
is that out of the 100 billion dollar
valuation
let's say that if if some whoever is a
ten percent or five percent stakeholder
of uber
they've taken a big risk and they may be
worth at five percent would be worth
somewhere around
five billion dollars and so out of the
five billion if the proposal was
how about instead of you having five
billion dollars of equity
what if you had four and a half billion
dollars of equity
and the other 500 million dollars of
equity
was distributed across the drivers and
the passengers
that actually made you able to have four
and a half billion dollars
and then that's interesting that's when
that's when everything clicks
more for people usually um because they
took that big risk they deserve a big
reward a big payoff
but it's just instead of getting a
ridiculous amount it's like you get in a
ridiculous amount and a little bit less
so that everybody can be more well i
definitely believe in that
yeah the the the passengers that's
interesting break that down a little bit
more how because i mean
you're essentially paying your customers
well the idea is that the wealth
creation engine itself is literally
the reason why it happens is you have
the rube goldberg moment of the
entrepreneurs the founders that they can
get invested by the venture capital so
these are the people that take the most
risk and then the next people that take
the most risk
are the employees the employees that
build the software and the technology
that enable people to just use their
phone in their car
to become a driver and get paid so those
are the people that take the most risk
they deserve the most payout yeah the
next people that deserve the most payout
are the people that in 2012 were the
first ones that decided to work for uber
not in terms of employees but in terms
of drivers and riders yeah
drivers and riders so what happens is
you have basically a titrated
scale from 2012 to 2021 look by the way
this is the same thing we're describing
with bitcoin
it's the same thing as in literally in
2008
people who came on board early on to
bitcoin
are the ones that got the most
disproportionate payoff
they have they have they own the most
equity and people that are trying to get
into bitcoin and other crypto in 2020 or
2021
are uh getting less of a payout but by
the way you're still
today you should still get into
cryptocurrency because
in 10 years you're gonna be like [ __ ] i
should have gotten into crypto in 2021
so um because it's going that way and so
the again it's just a simple idea is
that
people in 2012 that were driving and
riding on
on uber they should get a slightly
disproportionate amount of
shareholders tokens or shares compared
to people that are driving and riding on
uber in 2020
but then there's another sort of little
asterisk which is if somebody only
uh took gave let's say somebody only
gave 500 uber rides in 2012
but somebody in 2020 is giving 20 000
uber rides uh to people they deserve
um more in two thousand twenty two
thousand twenty one so twenty two is
giving twenty thousand uber rides that
then
it makes sense to actually also um
distribute
uh potentially slightly more equity
again to the that person so
um but i just want to say one one thing
one thing one more thing
not just one no you got you got at least
ten more things right now i have all
kinds of
things but i rather than spending
because this is interesting i love
talking about inclusion
let's stop i got one more thing i got
one more thing for you okay no no no
because i
want to i just want to revisit
consciousness before we end that's all i
want to say
that's because we literally just every
every time i think it was very clear
and there's never there's never a
conclusion right that's kind of the
point of that conversation as leonardo
da vinci says
art is never finished it's only
abandoned so i got one thing for you
though
so you got me on on the uber thing up
until we pay the customer because
what i don't understand how about that
is the fact that
the whole purpose of a company is to
provide enough money in the market that
people will take the risk to purchase
the thing
even if it's new if uber would have
never got their first customer they
would never be what they are now right
but that person had to take that leap of
faith and that risk
you know how you pick i'm gonna give you
five dollars exactly you know how you
pay 20 bucks for the ride
right yeah okay so you pay 20 bucks for
the ride
you're generating uber a slow at that
time maybe only worth
um uh 25 million
uh in 2012 or whatever the number was
and so you're paying in 20 then you're
paying 20
the next week when you take an uber 20
the next week when you take an uber
before you know it here's my point after
eight years from 2012 to 2020
you've potentially paid 50 000 to uber
yeah maybe
maybe okay let's just play with this
example if you've paid 50 000
to uber from uh 2012 to 2020
my pitch would be something along the
lines of this that
your 50 000 that you've paid into uber
has
actually helped create uber's
valuation of 100 billion dollars
so my my my question would be
what small tiny percentage of shares and
tokens
of uber's 100 billion dollar valuation
did you catalyze
that would be my only question and then
my following my
my following question would be um
how what kind of architectures do we
need to have in place
where that person can we can very
clearly visualize the data
that tells us that for eight years you
paid in 50 grand which uber has
by the way it's so funny uber has all
this data it's just not visualized so as
in
literally uber knows how many rides
you've taken
where you've taken the rides how many
drivers they have how many rides those
drivers have
done for them how much wealth every
driver and every passenger has created
for them
uber has all of that data for a billion
people around here here's the thing
here's
and here's where i kind of maybe
diverted diverge with the the silicon
valley venture capital view of business
is that
remember uber's never made a profit so
their valuation in in some sense is
is is a theoretical abstraction right
and especially
i i i remember
the pool of money that a business has to
deploy and and
and and increase the value of their
tokens would be based off their
profitability right
if they're an unprofitable business you
can make the case that unless people are
hedging their bets and driving up the
cost of the tokens artificially there's
actually no real value creation right
until the the customers paying them
enough that the
the company can become profitable they
actually haven't created value yet right
because they've created value i would
call what they're doing
they're a hobby right now they've
created similar to what adam newman they
just don't have cash flow
that's what they literally do not have
yeah they've never made a dime
yeah they're they're literally it's like
an engine that you keep feeding more
fuel and fire but
it's never it's never you know it's a
founder you keep pouring
into but it's never made a forged tool
yeah nothing has
been spit out which is the service that
they provide to the planet
but and i know what their business but
their goal is to add people to the
service
their goal is to addict people to the
service so that when they get autonomous
vehicles and when they can't
and that's the only way uber is going to
become profitable we all know that well
not is when they remove the drivers
well the main the main yeah which is the
bizarre catch-22 but yeah
yeah so yeah i mean it's similar to
wework i mean they were
and they never made a dime and to me i
don't call that a business i call that a
hobby right
i call that a really expensive hobby
founded by some very generous investors
and that's so i don't know how you pay
your customers because that's actually
supposed to be the opposite they're
supposed to be creating the pot of money
you use to value your business to prove
profitability to prove that you brought
value to the market
and thus the stock should be priced on
should be based on the actual value
tangible value you're creating not like
a theoretical value
yeah i mean how does the business great
profit if you i agree great news but
that's this is economics i mean yeah
this is great nuance i i like i liked
the points a lot
on that on that riff that was that's
super solid you had me everything up
until paying the
i actually agree equity should be drive
i think that's a great idea
and i think it's a way better idea than
doing a guaranteed minimum wage for the
drivers i think having equity making
sure
yeah correct the universal basic income
needs to be universal basic stakeholding
so there you go just to
yes just to just to give you guys i
guess a small
let's see if we can do a small uh wrap
here for those that kind of
wanted this um a little bit more
directly i don't know if that's gonna
get you the shot that well
i'll try and um
i'll try and get you guys this actually
on this angle quick
what i want to do is just very quickly
um get you guys into
that that zone again where we kind of
got to unpack
um consciousness because usually as you
guys know
what happens is we spent probably a
solid
uh 75 minutes or so on
consciousness and unpacking it in
beautiful detail but then
um which we again we had a beautiful 30
or 45 minute bit
just now on a non-consciousness
related subject it's still related of
course everything's related to
consciousness includes stakeholding and
all these things we talked about
but consciousness is so as we said
elusive
and it it veils itself so much
that it it almost purposely wanders off
into other explorations rather than
itself
and so just to again guys the little bit
i'll just give you a little bit one as
we wrap here on consciousness so that we
have this so
again the idea is that we have a
a subject to object relationship
and again everything is under the
iceberg analogy
let's just start with that everything is
under the iceberg analogy
above water you have about 10 of the
iceberg
below water you have about 90 of the
iceberg
and what we see is we see a lot of
people
that are spending a vast majority of
their time with consciousness in this
area
which is something along the lines of
the subject
investigating the object but they're
immersed
in the object and it's a good analogy to
use the phone
in the social dilemma this is our next
analogy
is that the subject becomes aware of
their relationship to the object so
people become aware of their
relationship to their phone
so they begin kind of slowly in a sense
uh understanding what is in the icebergs
below surface layers and then the
subject
begin investigating other subjects
that would be something along the lines
of when evan and i
get to truly this this is like we gave
the example of
empathy when you kind of immerse
yourself in the shoes of another person
and truly try and understand their soul
but also when you try and empathize with
uh 800 million people that don't have
access to clean water and try and
catalyze solution to that
but also the subject investigating a
subject is also like
if you please try this we do this a lot
in spiritual circles around the planet
the idea is that if you just stay
completely
silent and just look at another human
in their eyes for 60 seconds so don't
laugh don't talk but just look at
another human in their eyes for 60
seconds
usually what occurs is you realize that
it is the one consciousness
experiencing itself and so
you're experiencing the one
consciousness through
someone else's perspective you
see right through that nice little
pupil you see the one right through
their pupil and they see the one
right through your pupil so that's a
great experience for you to have
for subject investigating subject
and then you have
the subject investigating itself so
that's where we talk about
know thyself so what does it mean if i
investigate my consciousness if i
investigate my awareness
if you go to the uh theravada buddhism
which is the most
direct conservative teachings of the
buddha or if you go to
zocchen which is another teaching of the
buddhist lineage or advaita vedanta
which is a teaching of
the uh lineage of of
of hinduism and the not the non-dual
direct path tradition
so you can sort of have a myriad of
these
uh zen the sufi mystic tradition i
already listed all a lot of these so
you can you can you can see how
the how the
self can investigate its own
consciousness and awareness
know thyself the delphic maxim written
on the temple of apollo
and then also the self and this is very
similar the self
can also investigate the whole
and right what you have here is you have
the magician that makes
the source that makes the that's like
the big bang that makes the creation
which is us 8 billion that are trying to
think what is my source
so this is basically very similar as the
self-investigating
itself and also the self-investigating
the whole
right holism so that's what i would say
is that's what we would potentially say
um is the this 90
so these things here are kind of like
the 90
bottom of the iceberg that is very
rarely um
explored as consciousness um
and then uh if you synthesize
symphonically
the individual in the usa with the
individuation
with the universality with the
sort of what india and china the
collective
if what you do is you you drain the bath
water from both of these
and you uplift the baby and you
synthesize them into one you get this
symphonic consciousness where you can
basically
hold the universal
the oneness at the same time as you can
be
a gifted individual artist
in the world that's the essence
of kind of where you know it's always
helpful that we had evan because
he was able to help draw out a lot of
this um
hopefully valuable insight around
where consciousness can try and go
beyond
just its relationship to
an object and it's immersion in an
object and never even thinking about
anything below
in the depths of the iceberg so that's
in essence
what i guess some of the cool stuff we
got to unconsciousness
and a bunch of other awesome stuff
that's right
by the way it's so cool this was only
our first sit down on
the theme of consciousness and the
nature of reality
together on the show normally yeah
formally yeah four million back
back alley back room yeah smoke filled
room conversations
there's been a lot of epic convos
yeah and
this is only the beginning in the sense
of not only like evan being able to come
on the program more often so we can
unpack this stuff
um but also for us to sort of
evan and i have been talking a lot about
the in the sense of kind of like what
what joe rogan achieved with sort of
being able to bring on
uh his closest friends right his people
from uh his uh sober october group and
stuff like that you know he brings a lot
of his friends on
and they sort of have this like vibe um
and a lot of people like that
but what we want to do is we want to
sort of upgrade that vibe
to um a vibe where we bring on
evan and and others higher level
thinkers and guests
where we can focus maybe three four five
people
all simultaneously very slowly
surgically and precisely
on subjects like consciousness and
metaphysics and sort of try and unpack
these wisdoms and also try and
disseminate them as memetic
gods to the rest of the planet via
animations
anthologies documentaries so we're
looking for people to help us on an
animation front so
if you're really good at animation and
you want to get involved with some of
the
memetic god visionary stuff that
simulation talks about
then ping me um simulation series
gmail.com the link's always in the bio
to our email so reach out for that
and then also another thing is imagine
this conversation we just had about
consciousness and metaphysics
imagine this conversation occurring with
the most famous people in los angeles
that's right so
we need the connections we're working on
it ourselves right now on getting
connected to the highest level people
here
and basically having them unpack
their thoughts about consciousness their
thoughts about the nature of reality
and in doing so what's gonna happen is
you're gonna have
you're going to have these influencers
that basically
not only themselves become more awakened
morally spiritually ethically
and then butterfly effect out to the
world but their millions of followers
that
watch them will watch them undergoing
the process and they themselves will
also get butterfly affected to inquire
into
what do they mean by these things i
maybe i should care more about them
so that's in a nutshell
what's what happened and what will be
happening here so
yeah get stay involved let us know your
thoughts in the comments below
fam we love you thank you for tuning in
evan wow
[ __ ] yeah all right brother yeah so i
guess i guess
i guess that's it yeah unless we want to
talk about there's one word on the end
there but i don't know if we want to
talk about that
that could be a good we could maybe
that's a weird interesting outro
why don't we why don't we be a complete
we're
we're i think we're totally done with
this episode what we should do though
is we should make that its own theme for
the next time we sit down together
absolutely and we're gonna
we're gonna you guys would never guess
what this word this word is yeah you
would have made
no relationship whatsoever to anything
we spoke about the last time
i was going to say well in a very
sophisticated way you know if you
analyze it on a deep level perhaps yeah
yeah no obvious connection exactly no
obvious connection so
you'll enjoy next time evan and i sit
down together there will be a subject
that will be
super interestingly different than what
we talked about
i feel like it maybe perhaps has never
been discussed on stimulation
it has been discussed in small nuances
along the way but
we and and we've had some people come on
the show specifically to talk about the
subject
and i'll actually take i think i can
think of one yeah i'll tell i'll tell
you about them
later but so um anyway uh we'll do that
next time it'll be a lot of fun
super epic uh round together love you
guys
thank you so much for tuning in
um again let us know your thoughts in
the comments below we'd love to hear
from you
and also check out the links in the bio
below to the show
again evan's links are going to be down
there for you to follow him
link up with him um and check out the
episode we just did with him on cannabis
architecture if that excites you
that was our previous episode together
and the one before that that we did last
year
in 2019 was called the ethos of
architecture so you can check that one
out
and then uh support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
people that are rocking your community
support them
and help them grow and flourish and help
us flourish as well
and let us know your thoughts on the
comments i mean that's it guys we love
you very much
thank you for tuning in that's it
investigate consciousness
investigate the nature of reality
do it more often make that a priority
and share that with others around the
world
and hopefully it will accelerate us to a
more fruitful
future there's some interesting stuff in
there about also we talked about
darwinian metaphysics and consciousness
exploring infinity and
we talked a lot about a lot of
interesting things so all of alan's
favorite subjects
certainly i think we hit a lot of
interesting tennis balls back that made
me
um there was a profound moment at your
house when i realized that i was being
um too uh hubristic
and that was very important for me to
become more humble
and i uh credit uh your
help with that and uh potentially a
little bit of
cannabis may have been that's right may
have been insightful
well i actually had one more item for
your list i think in the the the subject
object i think there's in in
in a psychological world there's a
there's another option and i don't know
where it falls hierarchically in terms
of its value
but it's the subject investigating
themselves
psychologically in terms of knowing
temperamentally
knowing where you're yeah because an
important thing to understand is is we
all
at least in my understanding of
psychology fits into what
is kind of actually a meta thing right
yeah and in the sense that there is a
typology in a
neurochemistry and a temperament that by
itself regardless of outside forces will
have a
an inbuilt interest in spiritual issues
right
and just to be clear or in this tangible
the subject all those things are kind of
there's a meta element the subject
if you remember the subject
investigating itself like we discussed
was not
only um the subject investigating itself
as a universal but it was the subject
investigating itself as an individual
which we which we included the things
you just listed which was
not only your roots and your fruits and
your dna who you are
in your moment to moment beingness we we
shall talk about that more next time
okay
i think it's a very very very very very
operative we'll add that i mean that was
we spent some time on my gosh okay love
you guys very much thank you for tuning
in stay well stay well we love you
execute
build your build the future the more
beautiful future that our hearts know is
possible
as charles eisenstein would say we love
you very much we'll talk to you soon
peace
is this are we still on no yep